small panda Power Ranger
so Power Rangers is a new movie based on
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers that kids
show from the 90s it was ultimately a
bunch of Japanese action series footage
that they didn't had American actors
fill in the gaps of when they weren't
Rangers and he's blended it together and
hey new show and while Power Rangers is
still going on they're like hey let's
make a movie about the Mighty Morphin
saga so here we are new movie Power
Rangers in this movie five teenagers
Jason Zach Billy trainee Kimberly
they'll stumble across these power coins
like a what are these and make them
super strong and then they find this
underground thing for this floating head
in a wall names or Don's like a you fly
over the Power Rangers and so now they
have to stop really evil Rita from
destroying the earth but I liked about
this movie first of all the actors of
this movie are good I got things like
good like a surprise but I don't know
them they could have been good they
could have been cracked they were
actually good I mean the backbone with
this entire story if they suck the movie
sucks
and they really surprise me to stand out
is Billy like Billy from the series if I
had to pick my least favorite Ranger
from the Mighty Morphin Power Ranger
saga Billy would be him in this movie
have had to pick a favorite Billy would
be him Billy Cranston that's his name
Zordon is played by Bryan Cranston I
think Billy's mom has a secret ninja
soon the reality of the situation of the
film is they don't really morph into
Power Rangers for the big action throw
down to the last part of the movie for
the last act in that the whole movie is
about them finding the inner light the
inner power like parappa the rapper
before them they gotta believe so really
it's a character story but as a
character story
I actually thought worked like when the
character is Jason Billy Zach trainee
Kimberly when they were on-screen I was
actually in it they didn't have to have
the super suits and all the super
fighting for me to be in it and that's
actually a big gamble for this movie to
do it could blow up in your face in this
case I felt it worked I also like Bill
Hader as Alpha Phi because else was five
in this series man that too cheesy is
robot ever yeah yeah yeah I know and you
take that robot you put Bill hader's wit
and voice talents in that robot you have
yourself a pretty cool droid and Bryan
Cranston I saw him as sorta I thought
that was a great pick I was like cool if
I want a floating head with a voice
Bryan Cranston's head and
voice would be the ones I would pick
that Elizabeth Banks as read advert when
you first start seeing Rita you're like
this is like horror movie and I actually
like that I like the horror movie angle
they were playing at Rita because that's
a scary sorcerers woman however you feel
like she's the one in a world where I
cannot quantify her motivation for the
role I just can't not psychic
sorry guys but it seems like she's the
one who's like look the source material
itself is cheesy so you can just have
fun and be kind of cheesy which is fine
that's a justifiable mindset for an
actor to have however when everyone
around you is giving it their all
totally speaking that makes the person
who's being cheesy or stand out like a
sore thumb I feel like that's what
happened with Reena Reena which is kind
of cheesy in part she was like a villain
you would see in the 60s or a cheesy
show like Power Rangers from the 90s you
can just kind of see the difference
between these actors who are like this
could be our big break and Elizabeth
Banks who's like I've had my big break
but I guess I'll do this now why not
just throw down at the end with the
Zords and all that I thought that was
really cool they did something really
neat with the Zords that I thought was a
cool take on the Zords but in the end
that Goldar is still a big monster who's
there just to cause destruction he's not
a character he's nothing really a big
blob of gold and as the action as fun as
it was there was one thing in particular
at the end that happened I was like
that's just corny as hell the cheesy
part actually coincides with the special
effects on special effects for fine some
of the special things like no most of it
is fine most of it completely works
couple parts in particular though when
they stand out they stand out
motivationally speaking with Rita there
are a couple times I was lucky I should
have zagged when you zag you made pretty
dumb call it's one of those dumb calls
like why do movies do that and trying to
be vague because I don't wanna spoil
anything for you but I'm just saying a
couple times you reflect on the movie
you're like that didn't make any sense
and read it did that thing guys in the
end Mighty Morphin Power Rangers was
surprising to me I was always looking
forward to this movie but in that hope
that it was going to be entertaining
wasn't the reality of the situation big
is probably going to suck in the end nah
I had a good time with it
I enjoyed it or a couple of jokes that
were throwing out in this movie I was
like that's kind of a matured tic one of
them from the movie kingpin but I'll
give it to you but in the end as an
old-school Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
fan I enjoyed the movie I enjoyed the
lead actors I had being the Power
Rangers I enjoyed Bryan Cranston as
Zordon I will say Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers was
good time no alcohol required and if
you're down on your power range is lower
there are a few things like oh they
borrowed that from that saga they
borrowed that from that saga not all of
them in the mighty morphin time frame I
thought that was pretty cool I picked
out about three different things from
different things of lore from Power
Rangers in general I'm very sure Andre
Meadows has found more I found three all
right guys so Power Rangers the new
movie have you seen it what did you
think about it or have you seen Power
Rangers what saga was your favorite are
you Mighty Morphin or you Dino Thunder
or do you think it's cheesy but whatever
one you like whatever you say in comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]